تحت قبه الكونجرس الامريكيه مجلسان مجلس
الشيوخ وثاني هما مجلس النواب الذي يعد
الادنى بالهيئه التشريعيه اختيار ممثلين
435 عن الولايات يتم بشكل مباشر استنادا
لتعداد سكاني يجرى كل عشر سنوات وتعيد
وفقه الولايات رسم حدودي مقاطعتها بمعنى
انه لكل من منطقه الحق بالحصول على ممثل
واحد في مجلس النواب كحد الادنى وبحسب اخر
التعداد وفد كاليفورنيا كان الاكبر فيما
تملكه الولايات المثل ممثلا واحدا فقط بعد
الانتخابات يتم انتخاب رئيس المجلس من قبل
اعضائه اي ان زعيم الحزب الفائز سيكون هو
رئيس مجلس النواب
صلاحياته مجلس النواب الامريكي واسعه تبدا
من اصداره ومناقشه التشريعات والقوانين
والتصويت عليها الى تعديل الدستور كما
يتدخله في التعيينات الرئاسيه ويعترض
عليها وبامك فيه اقاله الضباط الفيدراليين
ومحاكمتهم والمشاركه بتعيين مناصبه
بالمحكمه العليا واضمن صلاحياته ايضا
انتخاب الرئيس اذا لم يحصل اي مرشح على
اغلبيه الاصوات بالهيئه الانتخابيه يسمحوا
الدستور للمجلس بطرد عضو باغلبيته ثلثي
الاصوات وبالفعل تم طرده خمسه اعضاء في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده بتهمي فسد وبموجب
الدستور ايضا فان موافقه المجستين اي
النواب والشيخ ضروري لتمريره التشريعات
[موسيقى]